What are we making today?
What can we learn from Bobby Flay?
I'm just so excited.
I'm your student, teach me.
Just to sort of ties into, you know,
what not just been up to.
One of this secret ingredients
in this food is bone broth.
So we're gonna make a shrimp pasta utilizing
shrimp broth to really bring in lots of flavors.
You'd take the shells, you put some water in,
some tomato paste, some aromatics like onions, whatever.
And then in about a half an hour,
we have a very, very flavorful shrimp broth, and it's free.
It comes with the shrimp.
So you might as well use it and you have great flavor.
So we're gonna start with the pasta.
Now, there's a rumor out there that
you don't like the shape orecchiette.
Is that true?
You know what?
It's not that I don't like it.
I hate it!
(Bobby laughing)
Really?
I don't get it.
Why?
Because I'm like,
it's literally,
I'm like, don't give me
all that carbohydrate without being able to like
string the noodles.
I don't know.
They just really irritate me,
but you probably Flay.
You just don't like the shape of it.
You don't like the shape of it.
I don't like the mouthfeel.
But you're Bobby Flay.
So I was like,
guess what if anyone's gonna
like turn my orecchiette story around.
It's gonna be you.
That's a lot of pressure
Drew.
I know.
But I'll take this challenge.
I'm a dramatic girl, Bobby, you know that.
I know that's why I love you back.
I love you too.
Okay.
So we're gonna start cooking some shrimp.
We have some salt and pepper
and we're gonna put the shrimp right in the pan
a little bit of oil on the pan
and you have a hot pan and you put the shrimp in there.
And just make sure that they're sort of,
they're not on top of each other.
They each had their own little space in the pan.
Bobby, you actually did,
we have a clip here, a tape clip.
And I'm really excited
because it's very informative about said shrimp.
I'm gonna roll that really quickly
so everybody can watch.
Okay, perfect.
So you wanna buy and prepare shrimp
but don't know where to start?
Here are some simple shrimp tips.
Don't be afraid to buy shrimp frozen.
The majority of so-called fresh shrimp you see
at the store were flash frozen and thought for display.
It's better to defrost them yourself.
As for pre-cooked shrimp,
just say, no.
They tend to be dry and bland
when added to dishes.
You can buy shrimp in three varieties.
Shell-on,
which costs the least
but can take more time to prep.
Easy peel, which have been split and devein
and pre-peeled shrimp are easiest to prep, but pricier.
Now let's get those shrimp prepped.
To full-frozen shrimp, place in a bowl under cold
not warm running water for just a few minutes
then dry.
Devein the shrimp
with a paring knife or shrimp deveiner.
And those are our simple shrimp tips.
Enjoy your crustacean creations.
So our shrimp is about, you know,
three quarters of the way cooked at this point,
we're gonna take the shrimp out
and reserve them on a plate.
And in the same pan,
we're gonna take the garlic
and some of the crushed red peppers, just a pinch
of the crushed red peppers.
And you just want to,
you just want to kind of
move the garlic around.
But you don't want it to burn.
And then you're gonna take some of the shrimp broth
that we have.
And you should have some shrimp brought there.
Put the heat on high, and then
let it cook.
You want it to reduce a little bit, just kind of grade
to a boil.
And then as it starts to come to a boil,
we're gonna add the shrimp back to the
racks of each shrimp broth.
Okay, I'm waiting til it gets to a boil.
Right, so the shrimp will finish cooking in your broth
with the garlic and all those chilies and everything.
And the shrimp broth is really
what's gonna bring tons of flavor to it.
We are making shrimp orecchiette
with the best chef in the world, Bobby Flay.
And the shrimp broth
Thank you.
has been boiling and simmering and it smells so good.
Okay. And now, Bobby, where are we at?
Is it time to add our orecchiette?
Yes. We can add some orecchiette here.
Right about now should be perfectly.
Okay, and I'm going-
And strain it out a little bit.
Add some orecchiette in there.
And then this is when the pasta and the shrimp and the broth
will start to come together.
And then
we have some fresh herbs.
I have some fresh basil here and fresh parsley
and you always add fresh herbs, Drew
whenever you cook something you want.
It could be anything.
If could be pasta or rice dish or soup or whatever it is.
Whenever you're gonna add fresh herbs.
You always wanna add them at very very end
so it stay nice and bright and really green.
Nacho, can you keep it down.
I'm not done yet.
And then we're gonna add a little bit of butter.
Yeah.
For some richness.
A touch of Parmigiano Reggiano cheese.
Now, Bobby, I actually learned a very tough lesson.
The first time I was with your girl, Giada.
And then I redeemed myself on our second hang,
which is
that you don't, it's not a good idea to put the cheese in
while the pan is on the heat.
Right.
You wanna do it after,
otherwise it turns into a gooey snotty cobwebs.
So it's basically what I learned.
At the very, very last second.
Basically, you just want the Parmigiano
just kind of melted.
It's almost like you're seizing it
as you're bringing it off the heat
and to the bowl.
So you're almost treating it like soft, for instance,
you know, just like that.
If you have a lemon there, if you wanna
put a little lemon zest on top, that's obviously optional.
I kind of love the brightness of lemon, like a shrimp pasta.
Okay, I'm putting my cheese on
and
do I get to taste it now?
Yes, let's do it.
Right, you're gonna be the, let's see.
Uhm!
It's really light.
But the shrimp stuff really brings it tons of flavors.
(audience laughing)
All right.
It's amazing.
Right.
Oh my gosh, Bobby.
What?
Why is this orecchiette different?
There's something, I'm not kidding.
Maybe this is a new life orecchiette for you.
(Bobby laughing)
I knew if there was one person that could turn me around
it was you and I'm completely turned around.
And I'm not just saying this.
I thought it'd be really funny if I didn't like it.
(Bobby laughing)
It would almost make sense better segment
but of course I'm in love.
It's so good.
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh, Bobby, you've changed my life.
Okay, by the way, do you know what pasta I hate even more
than orecchiette?
What's that?
Pappardelle.
Really?
Yes. Will you please, please do a pappardelle dish.
Cause that pasta peeves me to no end.
You like mushrooms?
Love.
Yeah, I'll teach you a pappardelle
with mushrooms, which is just amazing.
You've totally changed me.
Now I want to tack pappardelle
cause I don't know what it is.
I just have a visceral reaction to it.
I think I'm like a child of the 80s from California.
I like a nice box spaghetti.
I do love fresh pasta.
I love a ravioli.
I love a tortellini.
Okay, Bobby, I hear that we have a little surprise
for our kittens who are up for adoption.
Yes, at Brooklyn Animal Action.
So Nacho is graciously donating a bunch of foods to
to the Brooklyn Animal Action.
(Drew and audience clapping)
Because, you know,(indistinct) support.
He cares about packs everywhere.
I mean, and he wants every cat to have a really
good home and have a good health.
So we're really happy to be participating
in that as well.
Well, Peach and I just want to say that we absolutely
send all of our love over to you and Nacho.
(upbeat music)